according to the hill the newspaper not
the raised area of land Democrats now
think their next nominee need not be
likable he or she just needs to win
which is funny it's not like Hillary
lost because of her sparkling
personality back pain is more appealing
what they mean is they want a fighter
someone who could throw punches instead
of retreating to Gwyneth Paltrow's flat
to mainline quinoa a fighter isn't
polite or normal but a formal but
aggressive bloods and sometimes even
rude meaning they're looking for their
trump for two reasons
one we may never return to the way
things were before Trump it's not enough
to tie the perfect Windsor knot or make
the most tasteful toast you got to be
interesting funny raw but also it seems
like ability means less when assessing
effectiveness fact is he didn't have to
like Trump to admit he's doing a good
job so far
sure the way Trump handled Tillerson
that lacked appeal his approach to
critics can make you wince but the tax
plan the renewal of our military the
decimation of Isis it offers some
optimism you don't have to like the boss
to admit the company's doing okay so for
the Dems it may be time to nominate an
adult with an actual plan not simply a
call for hope and change or an
undergraduates reliance on identity
politics a wish is no course of action
which explains why most places you find
a Democrat in charge you find an unholy
mess all right want go to you first you
agree with everything I had to say do
you got this the Democrats need like
some kind of their correlation to trump
they need their Trump their Trump they
need their Trump mean a celebrity know
somebody that doesn't adhere to the
typical traditional mode of a politician
or maybe their Trump is already Barack
Obama yesterday yeah that's how we got
trump yes that's right the other day
Boehner that said that we are in a
moment where you have to be like a
cultural phenomenon in order to win the
presidency that doesn't speak well the
parties or the structure or the
establishment but that's that would be
one argument yes to my mind the big
thing is here especially after the Conor
lamb inherent victory in Pennsylvania is
that if the next election is a
referendum on
Trump loses so he's got a dirty up the
Democrats so you need a Democrat who can
in fact engage and be a fighter and I
think that's what's different because
going back to george w people said
that's a guy you want to have a drink
with you wanna have a beer with them
yeah well maybe now joe biden who would
be at the top of the democrats list at
the moment is the guy you want to have a
beer with anybody but you need a guy
who's willing to get down and dirty with
tried a joe might not have the energy
jesse to keep up yeah he'll be older
than I think presidential at the time I
don't think Joe wants it but it's very
difficult to defeat an incumbent
president it's only happened a few times
in the last couple decades you had Bill
Clinton who was extremely talented and
kind of caught lightning in a bottle and
he had Jimmy Carter one-term because
basically the whole world collapsed and
gas prices were high and he was pathetic
mess and Reagan came along just at the
right time so I don't think they have a
chance at defeating him I think it's
going to be a lot closer than it was in
2016 but they do need someone that can
throw haymakers with President Trump but
they have to do it in more of an
aspirational way because if you get in
the mud with Trump you're gonna get
dirty and you're gonna get bruised up
and it's going to be tough to recover
Elizabeth Warren's not going to be able
to do it
Kamala Harris Booker Bernie I just don't
think they have the innate talent you
can't just draft someone out of the blue
talent has to bubble up and arise from
somewhere within the country and if I'm
looking at the list here and I have a
whole long list of Democrats I don't see
anybody with even small amount of talent
compared to this president it's
interesting though you know Dana they
did find Obama he was kind of drafted
right well he gave the speech in at the
Democratic National Convention in 2004
and everyone when said whoa who's that
and then you know three years later he's
the nominee that's I don't know if he
was drafted so much is in some ways he
was a phenomenon and he was the opposite
often people go for opposites but you
mention Bill Clinton and how he did well
one of the things that helped Bill
Clinton so much is that he lost his
congressional majorities in the first
midterm and then he worked with the
Democrats and then people go actually we
kind of like this guy I'm not saying
that's going to happen and it's quite
case but also the Democrats benefit this
year because there is no one face of the
party do
like Republicans benefited in 2010 when
there was no one face so they were
fighting against the president not just
one person that changes soon after they
choose a nominee Kimberly who do you
think is the feistiest Democrat I like
who's the one that will like well the
feistiest in my opinion would be
Elizabeth Warren she loves to battle him
and they do that Twitter battle like
it's like a Battlestar Gallactica beats
Twitter so but she's saying that she's
not gonna run now so she's gonna be up
against the thing is the number of
people I think they'll be like 15 or 16
I'm gonna be like the Redux of when the
Republicans all ran and then who's left
standing so I think everybody's gonna
try and throw their hadn't especially
since there isn't any Clinton family
member blocking the spot so it's kind of
wide open race to see who qualifies and
just one more thing John Kerry tried to
imitate Bush when he was I served in
Vietnam reporting for duty I don't think
that works I think you have to go with
us anticipate I think that you because
we were a nation at war exactly 11 and
that's what they wanted hey wait a
second work for Conner Lam marine yep
Conner Lam was closer to trumpet two
Pelosi no yes no he kind of said that
well anyway I mean his policies were
closer to Trump than Pelosi well he was
four tariffs yeah four unions
I mean yeah